держсекретар США Ентоні блінкен побував
у пкіні в контексті давно запланованої
спроби завадити погіршенню
американо-китайських відносин головним
каменем спотикання як і раніше
залишається Тайвань Влада КНР каже що
має намір повернути острів і Застерігає
захід від втручання мій гість У тайбеї
Міністр закордонних справ тайваню Джозеф
у чи дійсно острів
приречений ми знаємо що можемо
протистояти вторгненню Китаю у то час як
влада Китаю нагнітає ситуацію китайська
армія не приховує своїх намірів щодо
вторгнення на суші морі і у повітрі на
яку ж допомогу розраховує Тайвань від
Вашингтона та Європи чи обіцяли йому
ядерну парасольку які уроки виніс його
уряд із війни в Україні і чи справді
Тайвань зробив усе можливе щоб уникнути
конфлікту зі своїм величезним
сусідом джозефу у Ласкаво просимо до
конфлі
Дуже дякую
тіме цього року китайські військові
провели триденні навчання біля берегів
тайваню та заявили на весь світ що армія
КНР готова до того щоб позбавити Тайвань
будь-якої
Незалежності вам недовго
лишилося Так ми живемо під постійним
військовим тиском Китаю уже кілька
років про які ви сказали були дуже
інтенсивними в порівнянні з іншими
маневрами які ми спостерігали у всі ці
роки зокрема в них брали участь
авіаносці дислоковані на схід від
тайваню і ми стежили за ними не самі по
собі А разом з нашими партнерами та
однодумцями Чи можете ви уявити сценарій
за якого Тайвань з населенням мільни
людей виграє війну з півторамільярдною
країною нас про це запитують уже кілька
років а ми намагаємось підготуватися до
можливого
конфлікту наприклад зміцнюємо і
традиційний військовий потенціал і
гібридний адже в сучасних реаліях
гібридна війна мабуть важливіша за
традиційну
наприклад у війні в Україні багато хто
пророкував Що росіяни захоплять Україну
за кілька
тижнів але цього не
сталося українці вистояли українці
змогли боротися далі стримуючи
російських
військових Я думаю що їхня рішучість
їхня готовність до гібридної
асиметричної війни та міжнародна
підтримка змінюють ситуацію Це ті уроки
які ми винесли
тож ми намагаємося зміцнювати нашу
обороноздатність а рішучість нашого
народу до самооборони зараз сильніше ніж
раніше до того ж Тайвань отримує більше
міжнародної підтримки ніж раніше тому ми
знаємо що маємо можливість протистояти
китайському
вторненню ви дійсно вважаєте що ваша
військова підготовка є таким фактором що
стримує Китай ви сказали що китайські
лідери двічі подумають перш ніж
наважитися застосувати силу проти
тайваню і Неважливо чи станеться це у
2025 чи 2027 році а ви вже схоже
розглядаєте можливі дати вторгнення
Тайвань просто має бути готовим до
всього Але чому Тайвань не готовий зараз
вас уже неодноразово попереджали про те
що Китай має намір мирним чи
насильницьким шляхом з'єднати вас з
Народною Республікою як вони говорять
Чому ви не готові
зараз з огляду на сучасні війни ми
оцінюємо не лише військовий потенціал
агресора його оснащення та
технології якщо поглянути тільки з цього
боку То може скластися враження що Китай
має перевагу над тайванем і Тайвань не
має жодних шансів
вистояти але якщо ви поглянете на
обороноздатність тайваню то я не думаю
що Китаю вдасться так легко захопити
Тайвань У нас багато зброї для захисту
наші військові також сповнені рішучості
захищатись Я думаю що наш народ також
рішуче налаштований зберігати свою
свободу та суверенітет якщо скласти всі
ці фактори разом Китаю буде нелегко
воювати з тайванем і швидко окупувати
його крім тайваню інші країни
розгортають свої збройні сили або
вживають заходів щоб стримати китайців
від розв'язання війни проти
тайваню Якщо ви поглянете на збройні
сили США розташовані в регіоні а також
той факт що Японія подвоїла свій
військовий бюджет на найближчі 5ть років
щоб підготуватися до можливої китайської
агресії в регіоні то думаю що китайцям
доведеться нелегко якщо вони розпочнуть
війну проти
тайваню Одна справа коли обидві сторони
проводять військові навчання але якщо
станеться гірше і почнеться війна чи
вірите Ви що якась інша країна воюватиме
на вашому
боці це гіпотетичне питання і ми завжди
говоримо вони всі гіпотетичні допоки
війна не почнеться Усі вони
гіпотетичні так якщо розпочнеться війна
то відповідальність за оборону тайваню
нестиме сам
Тайвань і ми маємо намір захищати себе у
цьому немає
сумніву але для інших країн На мою думку
головне - це продемонструвати свою
рішучість не допустити війни
Я думаю що для багатьох війна означатиме
економічну
катастрофу половина усіх контейнеровозів
світу проходить через тайванську протоку
90% найсучасніших комп'ютерних чипів або
напівпровідникових мікросхем
виробляється в
Тайвані якщо поставки буде зірвано це
стане ударом для світової
економіки
На мою думку багато міжнародних лідерів
зараз це розуміють і намагаються
запобігти
війні завдяки цим зусиллям переконаний
що війна не є неминучою на цей
момент це відповідь не зовсім на те
питання яке я поставив я хотів дізнатися
чи ви маєте залізні гарантії того що
інші держави воюватимуть пліч-опліч з
вами в разі китайського
вторгнення
так чи ні це дуже хороше питання
насправді ми намагаємося донести до
світу що захист тайваню - це наша власна
відповідальність тобто відповідь ні у
вас немає гарантій військової
допомоги Ми дивимось на це інакше
напевне знайдуться країни та люди які
захочуть надати тайваню підтримку
подібно до тієї яку США надають
Україні дайте нам зброю щоб ми мо дати
відсіч
агресору але власне бойові дії на
території тайваню - це наша
відповідальність США дуже розмито
висловлюється про те чи зможуть вони
допомогти чи ні така позиція може бути
спричинена політикою стратегічною
двозначності але це також може означати
що США ще не вирішили як діятимуть у
разі нападу на вас Як ви вважаєте що
вони
зроблять насправді Тайвань і США
перебувають у тісному контакті з приводу
до можливого розвитку подій із питань
того як підготувати Тайвань
якнайкраще зокрема які види озброєнь
можуть знадобитися тайваню яка стратегія
потрібна тайваню і які види навчання
будуть потрібні збройним силам США
надають тайваню такі ресурси проводять
навчання та підготовку ми вдячні за ці
зусилля рішення США про те чи брати вони
участь у війні чи ні приймає президент
країни але щодо тайваню це наш обов'язок
захищати
Тайвань ви хочете сказати що просто не
знаєте що робитимуть США у разі
вторнення на
Тайвань як я уже сказав ми підтримуємо
тісні контакти із США і відповідь на це
питання взагалі залежить не від
мене Я сподіваюся що Тайвань та США
продовжувати тісно взаємодіяти один з
одним у процесі
підготовки пане У 22 травня за
повідомленням typ News ви підтвердили що
зі США обговорювалося питання про те чи
буде Тайвань взято під американську
ядерну парасольку Як деякі інші країни
регіону Яким є результат цих
переговорів ми ведемо всебічні
переговори Зі сполученими штатами
подробиці змісту таких переговорів я
повідомляти не можу
пане у як ви розумієте слова президента
байдена у вересні Минулого року його
запитали чи він готовий взяти військову
участь у захисті тайваню і він відповів
так ми взяли на себе таке зобов'язання
ви тлумачите це як надання вам зброї для
захисту відповідно до закону про
відносини з тайванем чи як готовність до
участі у прямій військовій конфронтації
з
Китаєм як ми розуміємо це зобов'язання
ґрунтується на законі США про відносини
з тайванем США підтверджують свої
зобов'язання щодо безпеки тайваню
надаючи достатньо засобів для
самооборони а Якщо звернутися до закону
про відносини з тайванем то в ньому
також йдеться про те що США мають
підтримувати достатній потенціал для
відбиття будь-яких військових загроз
ззовні в цьому
регіоні Таким чином особливе ставлення
сполучених штатів до тайваню та регіону
є досить очевидним і за словами
американських офіційних осіб Вони мають
намір і надалі йти цим курсом і ми у
цьому не сумніваємось Сполучені Штати
постачають нам зброю займаються її
обслуговуванням та навчанням
користування
нею завдяки цьому відносини тайваню і
США в галузі оборони за останні кілька
років значно
покращилися Як ви знаєте держсекретар
сшані блінкен зустрічався з китайськими
лідерами колишній Міністр закордонних
справ КНР ціньган попередив США не
сперечатися з пекіном щодо статусу
тайваню за його словами тайванське
питання - це ядро інтересів Китаю
ключове питання відносин зі США і
найбільший
ризик як ви це
Розумієте я це розумію як те що
китайська загроза тайваню ясна і
очевидна і ми повинні поставити до неї З
усією серйозністю але водночас Як я
розумію держсекретар блінкен також дуже
чітко сказав що Сполучені Штати
виступають проти будь-якої
односторонньої зміни статус кво це
означає що США виступають проти
будь-якого застосування сили китайською
стороною проти тайваню і це не єдина
країна і не єдиний світовий лідер який
говорить про
це на саміті Великої сімки на саміті ЄС
США або на інших важливих зустрічах
лідери постійно наголошують на
важливості миру та стабільності в
тайванській
протоці а також виступають проти
будь-якої односторонньої зміни статус
кво у цій частині
[музика]
світу багато хто виступає проти
застосування сили останнім часом у
Європі навіть почали говорити що мир і
стабільність у тайванській протоці є
невіддільною частиною глобальної безпеки
та процвітання з огляду на це я
упевнений що застережень міжнародної
спільноти проти застосування Китаєм сили
чи спроби анексії тайваню було достатньо
Ми сподіваємося що міжнародне
співтовариство і надалі приділятимуть
належну увагу намірам Китаю застосувати
силу проти тайваню Тобто ви вважаєте що
гучних слів міжнародної спільноти і
Заходу достатньо для стримування Китаю
було багато сильних слів на адресу
Володимира Путіна перш ніж він почав
вторгнення в Україну але війна у все
одно розпочалася можливо дипломати нині
перебільшують значення слів
Це дуже хороше питання насправді окрім
гучних слів ми також бачимо що країни
роблять конкретні
дії демонструючи свою рішучість
забезпечити мир та стабільність у цьому
регіоні Сполучені Штати Японія
Великобританія Канада та інші країни
регулярно проводять
і забезпеченням Свободи навігації у
цьому
районі багато з цих кораблів проходять
через тайванську протоку і такі дії це
підкріплення їхніх рішучих
заяв Я вважаю що всі країни про які я
згадав зацікавлені у мирі та
стабільності в тайванській протоці і
підкріплюють конкретними діями свою
риторику чи не переймаєте Ви що
покладаючись на допомогу
Вашингтона ви стаєте заручниками не
найкращих відносин США і Китаю і що
Пекін може тиснути на вас просто для
того щоб послати сигнал
Вашингтону чи не ризикуєте ви стати
пішаком яким грають обидві
сторони це питання часто ставлять І в
Тайвані насправді деякі люди тут у
Тайвані стверджують що світовий конфлікт
розгортається між США і Китаєм і тому нь
має стояти осторонь від перепалок цих
двох гігантів і бути нейтральними Але
мені здається що реальна ситуація
складається інакше Річ у тім що тайваню
погрожує Китай а США намагається надати
тайваню
підтримку такі дві константи і ми живемо
за цих двох
констант тому вкрай Важливо щоб Тайвань
продовжував зміцнювати свої відносини зі
США з одного боку і намагався запобігти
війні ні з
іншого а щодо наших відносин з Китаєм то
можу вас запевнити що нинішній уряд має
репутацію відповідального гравця на
міжнародній
арені Ми хочемо зберегти мир та
стабільність у регіоні підтримуючи
статус кво і ми вважаємо що статус кво
відповідає інтересам усіх зацікавлених
сторін На мою думку тієї самої позиції
дотримуються Сполучені Штати Канада
велико
та провідні Європейські країни Ми
йтимемо цим шляхом щоб не дозволити
Китаю думати що він може швидко захопити
Тайвань Та івань не виступатиме у ролі
провокатора але ми також не піддамося
китайському
тиску чи була позиція заходу щодо Китаю
достатньо твердою раніше ви
звинувачували Європу та США у тому що
вони не протистояли закону Про
національну безпеку Гонконгу який
ухвалив Пекін це призвело до порушення
там прав свобод що захід міг зробити
щодо
Гонконгу Гонконг - це
трагедія це сталося на наших
очах закон Про національну безпеку був
нав'язаний місту де люди звикли до
свободи і
відкритості і раптом усі ці права були
відібрані китайським
урядом Ми не вважаємо це поодиноким
випадком щось схоже ми рігали 14-го року
в Криму коли реакція заходу на дії Росії
була недостатньо
чіткою Я вважаю що Це вплинуло на те що
розпочалася війна в
Україні і східній Азії якщо ми не
зробимо конкретних кроків проти дій КНР
щодо Гонконгу Я впевнений що китайці
сприймуть це як свого роду заохочення до
більш активних дій в інших частинах
світу особливо в цьому регіоні дії Китаю
у східно-китайському морі вже змусила
Японію сильно понервувати Якщо ви
подивитеся на південно-китайське море то
воно є більш серйозним вогнищем
напруженості ніж тайванська протока тому
я вважаю що міжнародне співтовариство
має серйозніше дивитися на китайський
експансіонізм та нав'язування
авторитаризму у цій частині світу ми
маємо зробити конкретні дії щоб сказати
Китаю що Ні він не може розширювати свій
вплив у ці ча світу ціною скасування
демократії Чому б не спробувати
поговорити з Китаєм інтенсивніше ваш
президент заявив що відкритий до діалогу
з пекіном без попередніх умов але навіть
люди у вашій власній партії вважають що
ви недостатньо стараєтесь один із
засновників партії хунчічан нещодавно
сказав у нас тепер така тверда
тайванська ідентичність і ми достатньо
впевнені в собі щоб розпочати переговори
з Китаєм про досягнення будь-яких угод
То чому ж ви не берете участі в них як
наприклад партія
гоміньдан ми
намагалися але ситуація така що Китай
нав'язує тайваню свої
умови умови було озвучено сізіньпіном 2
січня 2019
року я не думаю що будь-який розсудливий
лідер тайваню прийме або має прийняти ці
умови ці умови мають на увазі що Тайвань
має визнати себе частиною КНР Тайвань
має прийняти модель Одна країна дві
системи Тайвань не повинен погоджуватися
ні на що крім об'єднання з Китаєм А це
те із чим не хочуть миритися жителі
тайваню і тому навіть коли гоміньдан
повернеться до влади я не думаю що вони
зможуть або мають прийняти ці попередні
умови якщо ми приймемо такі умови
Тайвань стане ще одним го конгом і буде
пізно нарікати на те що Китай
запровадить на Тайвані черговий закон
Про національну
безпеку Отже якщо війна таки почнеться
Чи зможете ви поклавши руку на серце
сказати що зробили усе можливе щоб їй
запобігти Ми стараємось дуже
стараємось з одного боку наш підхід
полягає у збереженні статус кво миру та
стабільності у тайванській протоці а
також можливості запрошувати Китай на
переговори а з іншого боку ми зміцнюємо
нашу обороноздатність щоб не дати Китаю
приводу подумати що він зможе легко
захопити
Тайвань водночас Ми взаємодіємо з
Міжнародним співтовариством щоб воно
більше підтримувало Тайвань та
допомагало зміцнювати його
обороноздатність Ось таким чином ми
намагаємось уберегти Тайвань від війни і
не лише Тайвань У нас є партнери
однодумці вони розуміють у що обійдеться
Світова війна і ми робимо всее можливе
щоб її не
допустити міністре джозефе у Дякую вам
за участь у програмі
конфліктзон Дякую пане
[музика]
себастіян